الي في الريان معنى زميل مجيد بطنين مجيد
كيف تصف لنا الاجواء قبل هذه القمه
المرتقبه بالنسبه للارجنتين واستراليا
[موسيقى]
نعم حمزه تحيا لك ولي ضيفك الكريمين لكل
المشاهدين الجزيره المباراه بين الارجنتين
واستراليا التاريخ وفارق الامكانيات ربما
يصب في مصلحه التانجو الارجنتيني ولكن
طالما ان هذا المونديال هو مونديال قد
تحدث المفاجاه الكبرى هنا في استاد احمد
بن علي ولو ان الامر مستعد لان المنتخب
المدويه همم امام المنتخب
معي بعد الجماهير الارجنتين التي تريد ان
تحتفل بالمباراه ميسي
ارجنتيني قنال على كبه
استراليا ستيشن
الاستماع الى ما قالوه بينما المشجع
الاسترالي يقول بان بعد الاداء الكبير في
دور المجموعات ممكن للمنتخب استراليا ان
يكون همم يعني همم او يشكل صعوبات المنتخب
الارجنتيني في مباراه الليله حمزه برغم
انهم يعترفون بان المنتخب الارجنتيني قوي
جدا في المباراه في هذه البطوله وهو جاء
من اجل التتويج باللقب العالمي للمره
الثالثه في تاريخ اذن ننتظر مباراه كبيره
بين المنتخبين الارجنتيني والاسترالي
المتاهل سيواجه المنتخب الهولندي حمزه
سينا
ذكرت انه مفاجات كثيره في هذا المونديال
المفاجات انه نتفاجئت اليوم انك تحكي
اسباني كنت عايش في اسبانيا مجيد واحنا ما
ندري ولا كيف ههه
يعطيك الصحه مزيد ماذا عن الاجواء في